-David, it's so lovely
to see you.
-Hi, Seth Meyers.
Good to be here.
-Hi.
-You're on a real set.
You're on your set, unless you
remodeled your house.
-No, this is the real set now.
Yeah.
Yeah, week two of trying to
pretend like things are normal.
-Okay. An odd thing happened
to me just now.
I'm in my office,
and I realized that,
you're going to be on TV
in a few minutes.
So I went to -- I thought,
"Oh, my God,
I better, like, spruce up."
I went to the bathroom
and sprayed my armpits with...
you know that air freshener
stuff?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-That we keep in the bathroom.
And I thought,
"Oh, that's good.
I'm going to smell okay
on television."
[ Laughter ]
-We don't have that
technology yet,
but I would love to --
if we could get smell
through Zoom technology,
that would help.
David, your show was
the last Broadway show
I saw before
everything shut down.
And it is an incredibly
optimistic,
uplifting show that felt
very necessary for that time.
It seems even more
necessary now.
Is it a show that you hope to
get back on stage again?
-Yeah, yeah, we hope to get it
back on stage.
I think it's gonna be --
realistically,
I think it's going to
be about a year.
-Mm-hmm.
-I mean,
there's the vaccine
and there's how long
it takes the vaccine to
get out there,
and how long for people
to feel comfortable,
even with masks on,
sitting right next to strangers,
because, you know,
the Broadway thing is
you can't do Broadway theater
with 25% capacity.
-Of course
-It has to be like 80%.
And so -- Yeah.
That might take a while.
That's okay.
We've got this movie
coming in the meantime.
-Now, so this is -- you
have this production filmed,
and you had it filmed by
none other than Spike Lee.
How does that collaboration
come about?
-I texted Spike.
[ Light laughter ]
Yes.
Text is a wonderful thing.
So...
We'd crossed paths
a few times,
and so I had his text number,
and I -- there was --
there were stirrings
that somebody might want to make
a movie of this show,
so I texted him and said,
"There's -- Somebody might
make a movie of this.
Do you want to come see it?
Check this out."
So, he came to Boston.
It was a two-show day.
We do two shows on Saturdays.
And by the second show,
afterwards he came to
my dressing room and said,
"I want to do this."
So then it was like, okay,
get the money in place,
and all that kind of stuff.
It was kind of a scramble
to get it all together.
And it worked.
I was thrilled,
very, very, very happy
with the way it came out.
-I was wondering,
for someone like you,
that obviously you're on stage.
It's not something that you --
I'm assuming in rehearsals
you step back and watch things.
But are you someone who can
enjoy watching yourself?
Like, when you -- is it nice
to have this sort of
now timestamped moment of when
you were doing this show?
-I realized when I saw
the first cut
that Spike and the editor
showed me,
that it's the first time
I've seen the show.
And I thought, "Oh, my God,
I've been doing this
for a couple years now
and I had never seen it."
And of course, I'm looking
and going,
"Look what they're
doing back there.
Look what those other musicians
are doing back there.
I had no idea they were
doing that."
But also, in general, though,
I'm a little older
than I used to be.
I don't take as much pleasure
looking at myself
as I used to.
-Well, there are --
It should be noted,
there are a lot of other
musicians on stage
for you to look at, so...
-Yes, there's very handsome
and beautiful musicians
on stage, yes.
-I wonder, you know, you --
for my money and for a lot
of people's money,
you made the greatest
concert film of all time,
"Stop Making Sense,"
and I wonder
if there was
anything from that
that you brought into this
insofar as what you wanted
to be grasped
from a live performance?
Because this does have
such energy,
the same sort of energy I felt
when I was in the audience.
-Um, with
"Stop Making Sense" --
Oh, gosh. I know.
I know. I know. I know.
It's a tough bar.
Jonathan raised the bar pretty
far, and so did we, the band.
But, I think we're up to it.
I think we're up to it.
There was a moment during
the filming where Spike,
who was good friends
with Jonathan,
kind of looked up to the ceiling
and goes,
"Jonathan, how we doing?
How we doing?
I think we're doing
pretty good here.
[ Laughter ]
-That's fantastic.
We also talked --
you have a magazine,
"Reasons to be Cheerful."
And you're starting a new,
I guess...
maybe you can describe it
to us,
the "We Are Not Divided,"
it's sort of a project
that is, again,
has this same sort of optimism,
that in this time that,
you know, were you to watch,
you know,
cable news most of the day,
you would think that
there's two halves
of this country.
But you sort of have found
that maybe people are
more similar than
we're willing to let on.
-Yeah, so I have this kind of
solutions journalism...
website, magazine
that we look for, well,
evidence of people who
have found solutions to things
that we think maybe
are intractable.
And my colleague suggested
that, well, kind of
in the run-up to the election,
that we do a series
called "We Are Not Divided,"
where we report on instances
where people are actually
bridging the gaps between
themselves
and finding that we're not
maybe as divided
as we are
led to think we are.
I know.
So when they first
proposed this,
I responded and said,
"Are you kidding?"
You know, I mean,
I wake up in the morning,
I read the papers,
and I think we're all
ready to kill one another.
And they said, "Can you show me
some examples?"
Which they did, which they did.
And I said,
"This is really great.
So let's do this.
We're going to do this
for, I don't know
what it is,
like, six weeks or so
up until the election.
And hope that it will make
people realize
that maybe we're not as
divided as we think we are.
-I will leave it on that,
because as always,
I am in a better mood after
I see you than I was before.
That is true whether we talk
or whether I see your show.
And I'm so glad that those who
weren't lucky enough to see it
on stage can see it on HBO.
And it's just always
a delight, David. Thank you.
-Thank you very much.
Good to see you again.